eu sou a maria isso natural de são borja
é das missões divisa com a argentina é
nasce quando eu nasci no médico
desenganou minha mãe não sabia o que eu
tinha mas a minha mãe me levou pra casa
me cuidou me deu leite de cabra tomei
graças a deus bibi foi muito leite de
vaca quentinho
eu era tão grande que cabia na caixinha
de sapato
depois desenvolvi tá aí passou passou
aí a gente cresceu a gente pula a
fogueira fazer a fogueira na festa de
são joão e e pisar nas brasas a quem
pisava na prática é o que causava mais
rápido eu nunca quis isso aí e é esse
cresceu depois da minha fofa cuidar um
parente lá no bairro do passo a gente
foi
era um quando é calor horrível muita
seca braba todo mundo entrava no uruguai
aí eu fui eu não ia lá aí lavava naquela
pedra lá aí eu pegar pra a gente
brincava na beira do rio eu pegava sabão
me atirava assim pra pegar os peixes
peguei muito peixe no rio uruguai que o
sabão aí todo mundo duvidava mas
primeiro está conseguindo guria tem aqui
eu vou mostrar pro senhor vai ver lá e
pegar você precisa tirar os vizinhos ea
gente limpa como ele mesmo aqueles peixe
passou e depois quando é viu o carro
fúnebre nós tinha medo daquilo para
aquele pois a feio assustavam a gente
que um pedágio e não era pra teimar que
aquilo ia pegar e levar a gente precisa
interno chorava de medo daquele seio
aí passou ta ai nove anos já comecei a
cozinhar fazer uma rose uma coisinha que
pediu pra mim fazer lá no céu quando em
casa pra ajudar tá
depois passou estudei no quartel do 1º
até a 4ª série
no quartel se estudavam quem era ele
militar com minha avó lavar o coronel
que passar serviço pra ele aí eu fui
estudar no quartel
lá no quartel é muito bom o lanchinho
deles quando ficou em evento a gente
para os alunos participavam do evento
acoplaria da orquestra muito bonito do
quartel depois agora termina após muitos
anos terminou o colégio do quartel já
passou
aí mas a gente foi crescendo foi
desenvolvendo queria evoluir ainda um
irmão vieram pra cá outros foram
produzidas adi e eu queria tem muito pra
cá aí a minha mãe dizia é muito perigoso
menina é ruim ea mulher é ruim agora o
homem tem que deixar sair um pouco a não
eu vou cá para conhecer a enfim que e
aquilo
passei muita dificuldade me ambientar
pegar o ônibus a sair
passei muito frio mas passou um deus dá
o frio conforme a descoberta
aí tá aí trabalha metalúrgica trabalhei
fábrica de roupa produção trabalhar em
supermercado carrefour nos afro
trabalhei em outros lugares até chegar
no anchieta eu nunca tinha trabalhado em
um colégio
será que ela vai dar recado nunca
trabalhou não gostei de ser visto até
hoje graças a deus ainda passou um tempo
com dois anos que estava aqui eu
perguntei por lançar só não podia
arrumar alguma da aula pra gente algumas
o professor aí a então me consegue umas
dez meninas que eu vou conseguir iphone
com as good árvores vão estudar vão
aproveitar fazer alguma coisa aí tem
vergonha maria agente de limpeza maria
sirvam dá risada maria que nada criavam
estudar as gurias não ficaram com
vergonha e não conseguirá passou faz um
tempo depois de 30 anos voltei a estudar
terminei o ensino médio no ano passado
que no darcy ribeiro com a ajuda dos
professores aí vou eu me senti pará tem
que voltar a ficar aquele medo assim aí
me encorajei me foi passou agora eu de
realidade de realidade para o esquecido
uma menina
o que era pra rodar por aí
aí passou a essas guria que estão
querendo volta à cidade não tem vergonha
que volte a estudar pobreza não é
defeito defeito não querer progredir
volte estudar melhorias vão conseguir
aquilo que quer na vida eu tiro na
faculdade de segurança o trabalho graças
a deus com a ajuda dos colaboradores dos
outros jogadores doentes deus quiser
quero que deus me dê mais saúde pra mim
vencer todas as barreiras que eu tenho
na vida é assim e agradeço a todos muito
obrigado a compartilhar com vocês nós
com de cada dia